The mice and the men ate the same food.
They lived in the same houses.
But they did not like each other at all.
The mice said the men ate too much food.
The men said the mice gnawed the walls of the houses.
The mice and men decided to go to war.
The men were sure they would win.
They were so much bigger than the mice.
The men did many things to get ready for the war.
They put new strings on their bows.
They put feathers on their arrows.
They made slings to throw rocks at the mice.
Before the war, the men had a big war dance.
The dancing made them very tired.
They all fell asleep.
Then the little mice crept into the room.
They gnawed the strings of the bows.
They cut the feathers from the arrows.
They broke the slings with their sharp teeth.
Then they gave a great war yell.
Squeak!
The men woke up, and they saw the mice.
They reached for their bows, but the strings were gnawed.
They picked up their arrows.
The feathers were all cut.
They took up their slings.
Every sling was broken.
The men had nothing to fight with.
They could not drive the mice away.
The mice won the war, even though they were smaller.
Mice have been in men's houses ever since.